the threshold has been reached we have a
press release from graham brady the
chair of the 1922 committee saying the
threshold of 15 of conservative mps has
been exceeded and in accordance with the
rules a ballot will be held between 6
and eight p.m tonight and the votes
counted immediately afterwards and then
the announcement will be made so a vote
of confidence in boris johnson's
leadership to be held
she's so calm we're just hearing that
potentially the price prime minister
maybe i'm seated today today that let
that just sink in for you for just a
second you're watching us live here on
sky news breakfast programme outside
number 10 downing street where the prime
minister has lived since uh december of
12th his election was december of 2019
that was when he won the vote today he
could be unsuited yeah after three years
as prime minister this could it could
all end the prime minister faces a vote
of no confidence there's been a
rebellion building well over many months
really since the partygate allegations
came to light but particularly in the
last 10 days or so since the sugree
report and mp's taking in what that all
means and now the prime minister faces
the moment he no prime minister wants to
face a vote of confidence in his
leadership of course to win he'll need
the support of at least half of
conservative mps that is 180 but it is a
secret ballot and so he will be very
worried that his days in downing street
are very
numbered